you have a podcast called may i
elaborate daily wisdom from jb's move
and it's such a wonderful service
because
you people can tune in it's not a long
podcast every day you're putting out
great wisdom for people to get them
through the day and
you're probably who knows you might be
saving lives out there it's amazing
no we we help people every day conan i'm
only doing this podcast
because people need help we're trying to
get back on our feet here man i'm trying
to help people
i'm giving people concrete advice you
know and
here's what i do i take a simple
affirmation and people don't understand
these affirmations sometimes they get
confused
about what they what they mean like they
have one i talk about i got
we got one called roller coaster it's
absolutely amazing i just elaborated on
this amazing quote and i talk about how
uh when you're riding your life is like
a roller coaster
you when you get in the roller coaster
you go up this hill
and just click click click click click
click click click click click to talk to
your friends this is gonna be great oh
my god
i love this roller coaster click click
click click click click click click
and get to the top of that roller
coaster that entire
ride is your life your life is a roller
coaster
so i always say to people you enjoy that
ride enjoy that life
enjoy your ride on that roller coaster
your life is a complete now some roller
coasters have a loop-the-loop
maybe you got somebody pregnant or or
you know
or you asked me
you asked me to
lost you lost a job yeah or something
[ __ ] happened
you know but it's just a loop-de-loop
yeah you still got momentum
momentum you still keep moving that
one-click click click
and that one drop carries you through
your whole entire life
so i say enjoy your [ __ ] life until
those clicks
until those click click clicks become
tick tick
ticks i know
i [ __ ] know goddamn right hey
don't get me started i make all these
[ __ ] cry i make everybody
crying
i'm telling you so see what we take i'm
not sure i went along with that but
whatever yeah yeah
they seem happy you got it you got to
enjoy your life before those clicks
click click click
become tick tick ticks goddamn right you
damn right see
that's how deep we go sometimes but we
do it we're doing that
you go that deep oh we go deep we want
you to
laugh and we want you to understand
these affirmations we want you to apply
them to your life
see i'm a fixer i fix people yeah